[Music]
and they're not the squad
they're elon
they're alexandria and they're rasheeda
they are people they're our colleagues
if majority party gets to decide who
sits on what other committees
i hope you keep that standard because we
have a long list
you can work within your own
looking live at the vote there on the
house floor to strip marjory taylor
green congresswoman from georgia
of her committee assignments and they
have surpassed
the 217 needed for the majority in this
particular vote you see 230 to 198
11 republicans voting with the democrats
so far
the votes still open not gaveled yet but
they've surpassed
the majority needed time remaining zero
let's bring in our panel bill mcgern
columnist for the wall street journal
charles lane opinion writer
for the washington post and byron york
chief political correspondent for the
washington examiner
bill this is unique the republicans
decided they were going to say this
shouldn't happen
even though they did punish
representative steve king from
iowa doing more to him than they than
they came out of caucus
doing with marjorie taylor greene and
what she had talked about
and what democrats said were threats
specifically as well as conspiracy
theories now
the house is voting to take her off uh
the committees
your thoughts right well what you mean
is the democrats are voting to take her
off this uh
look i think actually today was a pretty
good day
right right but uh but they're over
they're overruling a decision the
republican conference
made a decision not to do this um i'm
not sure the democrats are playing a
good hand here i thought the republicans
did reasonably well today they left liz
cheney
um in in her job uh refused to
you know dethrone her because she didn't
vote the way other people wanted
and i thought they they dealt with the
new congresswoman
in this way look this is part of an
effort i think by the democrats
to portray all the republicans
as these crazy insurrectionist people
and i don't think that's true
i don't know where this um stops you
know a lot of this was about stuff she
said before she came in i mean i don't
particularly care for
but uh you know if we're gonna go after
every nut in congress
there's gonna be a lot of empty seats
all right here is representative taylor
green
talking on the house floor today
you see school shootings are absolutely
real i also want to tell you 9 11
absolutely happened and it's a tragedy
for anyone to say it didn't happen
and so that i definitely want to tell
you i do not believe that it's fake
i don't know what the hell happened to
the republican party
the party of lincoln the party of
eisenhower the party of reagan
is becoming the party of marjorie taylor
greene
so referencing there in her speech that
she had said
online that she didn't see a plane going
into the pentagon
questioned that and the parkland
shooting
as well chuck what about this action and
the retribution element to it
should republicans get the majority
well look it would be nice for the
republicans if what jim mcgovern just
said there was
totally untrue but unfortunately for the
republicans it's not
totally untrue marjorie taylor greene
got into her position with the support
of a lot
of republicans who are currently sitting
in the house
including the freedom caucus etc her own
republican
opponent called her quote crazy in the
republican primary and he
lost so this is a bed they have made for
themselves so i don't feel too sorry for
them having said that
it is a dangerous precedent because you
can be sure
that if the republicans get the majority
in congress
they're going to find somebody on the
democratic side to do this to themselves
and it just
you know will set off a cycle but you
know it would have been better
for all concerned if the republican
party retained a filtration power
on its own candidates and its own
processes to weed out somebody like this
who i repeat
her own republican opponent who was a
very conservative republican
considered crazy and so you know that's
that's on them yeah well
and the voters in georgia obviously
elected her as well in that district
let's turn